الساعة 20:00 بعد الساعة الخامسة صباحًا عند
مغادرة أثينا للفندق ، لا يزال الجو
مظلماً بالخارج رحلة طويلة إلى لندن
باللعب بالقطار من منطقة باردة نسبيًا
19 كوفات - واحدة من أعلى المناطق الساخنة في أوروبا.
اذهب إلى الكثير من التعريفات ،
اثنان منهم فقط دوليان ،
إنه حقًا حظ سعيد
للغاية ، لذا فهذا مثير للاهتمام قبل أن تتمكن من ركوب
هذه الرحلة ، فهم يريدون التأكد من
أن لديك اتصالاً إلى وجهتك النهائية
التي تسافر إليها إلى
وطنك أو  لديك سبب
للذهاب إلى بلد آخر ، إلقاء نظرة أخيرة على
اليونان ، الطائرة نظيفة هذه الأيام ، فأنت
تريد أن تكون متأكدًا بشكل مضاعف من شخص مثل
الرحلة عندما جئنا إلى هنا مغادرين على
هذه الطائرة ، يتعين علينا ارتداء قناع الوجه
وعندما تذهب في الخلف  في المقصورة ،
لم يكن هناك ما يقرب
من مقاعد مسافات اجتماعية من جميع المقاعد الثلاثة ، كانت تجربة غريبة تمامًا
على متن رحلة لمدة ثلاث ساعات ونصف
تقريبًا ، وطوال الرحلة بأكملها ،
ظل طاقم الطائرة خلف
ستاره لم يأتوا  هذا ليس
شيئًا رأيته من قبل
عندما أطلقنا سراحنا ، لقد قدمنا تعليمات Ovid 19 هذه إلى أن
ميع الأشخاص الذين يد
لون الأراضي البلجيكية ، لذا فهذه هي
للوائح التي تحصل عليها عند وص
لك إلى بلجيكا في بلجيكا يبلغ طولهم 1.5 مت
ًا  في المملكة المتحدة واليونان ،
كان ارتفاعها مترين ولكن هنا 1.5 متر
المحطة التالية هي جمارك جيدة
وقطار هل تقلق عندما تلتقط
الركاب من أن الراكب ربما
يعطيك الفيروس
، نعم ، ويؤثر عليها للحصول على فنجان قهوة أو
شطيرة أعني أنني أعلم أنك لم تأكل ،
تناولنا القهوة وفي أثينا في حوالي
الساعة السادسة صباحًا وفي
منتصف اليوم الآن ، لذا فإن القليل من
الكافيين سيساعدنا هنا ،
لقد بدأنا '  في وقت مبكر جدًا ، هذه
هي متعة السفر بالطائرة والقطار
عندما لا توجد سوى طائرة واحدة أو طائرتين
وقطارات ، هذا هو يوروستار الوحيد
اليوم ، لذلك سننتظر لساعات على عكس
الطائرة التي يكون القطار
فارغًا حقًا الذي تعلمناه للتو.  أحد
الموظفين هناك  لا توجد خدمة في
القطار اليوم ،
إنها حقًا عملية مجردة 14
ساعة ننسى هنا إلى لندن ، لكننا
جعلنا السفر الجوي قد تغير بالتأكيد ،
إنه أبطأ ، هناك عدد أقل من الرتوش ، هل
نتوقع أن يطرح حرس الحدود عليك المزيد من
الأسئلة ولكنك تعرف ماذا يوجد تحتها
يجب أن أقول إن كل شخص
لديه ابتسامة كبيرة ، نحن جميعًا في هذا معًا ،
هذا هو NIC Robertson الجديد ، CNN ،
بعض محطات Pancras